so everyone's connected these days
everyone's carrying a smartphone
especially parents and kids and when
parents are away on business on some
kind of trip you know they want to stay
in touch with their kids and even more
so than some skype call or phone call
before bedtime we want to keep connected
with their kids all the time here are
some ideas some apps some things you can
do with your connected devices to stay
in touch when you're on the road so
first up in the gaming apps category is
you know the classic chess the great
turn-by-turn game where one person can
check in make their move the other
person gets to it whatever they want
whenever they have time there are a
variety of chess apps available in the
App Store and just find the one that
fits you some of them are really good
for beginners too and have a lot of
guidance which can be great for kids of
course there's also a lot of social
gaming apps out there we like a couple
such as we rule or godfinger where
you're sort of creating your own Kingdom
your own world and generally these games
are free to play we have to watch out
for those in-app purchases and be
careful how much you let your kids by to
try and outdo you in the game one of my
personal favorites is called Carcassonne
actually a very famous a card / board
game that's been ported into iOS it
starts at nine ninety-nine but it has a
wealth of interplay ability you can try
many different modes to play and again
it's turn based one player can play and
then it sends pop-up notifications to
the other player when it's their term
but you don't have to buy an app just to
connect one of the best ideas is to use
the picture capabilities you know all
all these connected devices have good if
not great cameras you can make a great
game with your kids by taking pictures
of strange or interesting things you see
on your trip sending them to them via
email Twitter SMS whatever
and you know sometimes challenge them
say you know what is this where am I and
you know make a fun little sort of
scavenger hunts out of figuring out
where mom or dad is you know really in
the end it doesn't matter whether you're
playing a turn-based game you're a
social game sending pictures of places
back and forth or maybe even just taking
a picture of what you're eating each
night wire on the road you know the
point of all this is stay in touch
staying connected we have the most
amazing tools in all of history to do
this and it's just going to help you
feel like you're not that far away and
keep your kids happy and secure that mom
or dad you know is coming home